Добре? Тоді можемо загалом продовжити те, чим ми займалися на минулому, занятті і було б добре загалом спробувати з кимось, з вас виключають із Сергій олексійовича Якщо звісно, хтось працює з комп'ютера.
І має можливість завантажити або має віл-студію тобто цілком можемо з вами спробувати повторити ті які були презентовані над минулому, занятті.
Чи є в когось можливість?
Чи, можливо, в Наразі не просто не у всіх доступний у поточний момент тому, що потрібен час, На встановлення і таке інше.
Ну, що ж Павло провести ті проблеми? Які виникли в мене Отже, я вмикаю демонстрація екрану.
Добре, давайте.
І зараз спробуємо абсолютно типову ситуацію, як вона, власне, і мало бути?
Дуже розпочнемо з чого з того, що я все ж таки знайду де в мене той візол студії кот, він мабуть має десь бути так десь він є А ось означок, візит.
Так.
Ось Я його. Запустив.
за допомогою інтерфейсу тому ми будемо намагатися це зробити за допомогою терміналу, для цього зріло працюють на верхні панелі де ось файл едіт легше там, 3 крапки є у вас зверху або або ось тут можна от.
В а ось тут термін ось тут не у всіх тут є Давайте як то вашим способом 3 крапки і я маю ось тут терміново.
Так. Новий термінал.
Новий термінал новий термінал.
Першеса Ага Так. І він відкрився вниз фактично Тандем.
Так і де завівся.
Ага Тобто, якщо я перейду у довіру якесь там віконце А от і натисну ось тут знову новий термінал мене має кудись там переключити.
Ага. Тут. Вона вам вказує обрати робочий Директор: і ваш випуск простих дій.
Тому треба обрати тест-посталь.
Саме той з якими працюємо добре, і тоді термпол відкриється прямо там мені потрібно ви бачите тут унизу що у вас є повний шлях тест ре позитури наприкінці значить, те що потрібно чудово Отже, і що тут мені потрібно робити.
Так.
Перше, що треба зазначити, що у вашому випадку термінал може відрізнятися тому що в цьому випадку використовується екіпаж як основа якщо ви працюєте на сцені тема лінкс або серія вона встановлена так класичне за замовченням.
Термінал. У плюс є Пав Варшав Фактично, вони будуть відрізнятися. Дуже мало тому для вас це не буде грати великої роль А тепер нам треба за.
А покажіть, будь ласка, тоді як у вас у ваші віруси стоїть так, Давайте перемикаємо ви покажіть, як виглядає відповідний термінал упаршел.
Так.
Звісно, у моєму випадку, є їх встановлено. 2 тобто ось коли ми відкриваємо можемо закрити все ідемо до терміналу.
всі і відкриємо термінал то за замовченням у вас буде відкрито павша.
Неважливо, як у вас тип терміналу, і таке інше. Важливо, яку команду, ви Наразі тут ведете Значить, яку я маю вести як пересічний, користувач.
Тоді?
Так Тобто, команда, яку ви маєте вести це ось така але тут важливий елемент. Тому що чи є у вас встановлений кіт, треба я можу зараз зупинити.
Посилання загалом він завантажується як звичайний.
Ее Тато Так. Зараз?
Ось вона така тобто.
таке інше. Давайте я скопіюю. Посилання відкрию його умову.
Мені одразу ж визначила вибоглядач у вас буде пропонуватися для індус Наприклад, 64 амбітна Ну, я не знаю, можливо, мене було вже встановлено і таке інше.
У вашому вибоглядачі і подивимося що мені запропонується в мене інша операційна система Але у будь-якому випадку, я можу обрати ось тут що завгодно.
пошти і недовільна адреса а та адреса з якою ви вже є зареєстрованими на Гітхабі Ну давайте я спробую прибрати тут зайвікоїв Гігієні хворих Глобал Юзер крапка це властивість і тепер мені потрібно вказати мою адресу з якою я зареєстрований Нехай це буде реальна
Гіт-хобу Ось для гідхабу в мене є декілька облікових записів.
І для користувача. Оцього семиріков джемелку буде Оце ще пароль я можу його скопіювати ну а Тепер намагатимусь виконати. Команду якщо гід правильно встанов не все ось такий користувач, додався так павло Володимирович наступна дія яку має використати виконати користувач.
Г.
Так тепер нам треба вказати ім'я користувача власне воно встановлюється дуже схожою командою лише єдина відмінність що вказується замість і милу мейм і Загалом, у патрійних лапках ми вказуємо ім'я користувача.
Давайте спробуємо це зробити значить, замість юзер, крапка і мил я вказує юзер крапка ним, і це саме, те я буде прописуватися.
У горизонталі. Ви можете вказати будь-що, і вказує в якості свого ім'я А я Наприклад, можу вказати не Ось такий варіант Скажімо, Сергій семиріков Давайте спробуємо що це працює.
Зауважив: Це може бути українською мовою спокійно вказувати ваше ім'я зроблено Наступна дія.
Наша.
Добре, все ж таки тоді повертаємось до нашого управління контролем. Це третій до речі, бокові панельки це буде третій підпункт.
Ось якраз в нас тут щось є це воно не воно Перепрошую, оо треба правильно. Рахувати.
В.
Це п'ятий. У нас третій. Зверху.
Дякую. Тобто Оце управління воно якраз відображає Цей символ ви цю кількість ви побачите гілочки гілочки які якраз у нас і об'єднуються Так!
У.
Що ми бачимо, ми бачимо якщо я тут, все, по звертаю що ось наш репозитарій.
У нас були виконані певні дії. В репозитарі і всі вони Видимими і Власне кажучи, Ну, Тобто це 2 різні люди і у нас був сформований пакет але цей пакет не був відправлений Ну, що не коміт спробую натискати відповідно не що ми маємо тепер павло Володимирович будь ласка.
Тобто, як бачите, все ж таки, без повідомлення, ви не можете не стиснути помітного що вона все ж таки, змусить казати.
Що нам треба вказати якісь зміни, були зроблені у даному випадку якщо ви не вказували, це в текстовому полі зверху.
То вам треба буде вказати текстом що саме змінилось, то що нове.
Так це По-перше, не той і мені здається, що вам треба буде натиснути. По-перше, зберегти.
Контррозвідки. Добре Я Зберіг.
Так.
Так. Мені здається, що також упан якщо не помиляюсь. Можете опустити мене у нашому краю там з боку екрану.
Мені здається, повинна бути підтвердження так. Ось Бачите, перший символ з боку Ось така.
Давайте мені.
Ве галчка вона вказує на те, що так підтверджую тут прийняти.
Потрібно підтвердити. Зміни добре.
Так.
Приймаємо.
Добре, бачте, Тобто у вас з'явився графік Можна побачити ваш Комітет: мді.
У а давайте я зазирну. До репозитарію. Щоб подивитися його безпосередньо ось тут, Де ж наші зміни Власне, відбулися.
Яким чином я це можу зробити? Наприклад, Давайте я оновлю всю сторіночку А Де мої зміни Де моє щось?
Так. Тобто, змін. Немає тому що Сергій Олексійович лише створив коміт Поміт як Я зазначав, вони лише створюються локально, Тобто для того, щоб нам все ж таки надіслати до пропозицію в нас можна натиснути.
На 3 або синтез або натиснувши на 3 крапки ось тут вище не тут там, де вказуєте повідомлення каміту.
Ага, Тут багато трьох крапель.
Так тобто тут можна натиснути і тут буде.
Друге пуш тобто надіслати зміни його можна натиснути.
Значить, якщо я хочу отримати зміну, сервер я їх витягаю це буде якщо я хочу їх туди, відправити я натискаю відповідно пуш.
Або Сін або нудно зробимо наступний Крок о виявляється, що все ж таки, пароль мені буде потрібним тому що оця Надбудова гітхав очі.
Увійти до відповідного облікового запису ну що за цією метою мені якраз і намагається не виконати оця, первинна дія зазвичай знову ж таки, вона виконується лише 1 раз, що віже у студію код бажає авторизовуватися від мого ім'я в мене власне за адресою семиріков чи мілком є ім'я
користувача за замовченням? Можна Так, шукати Мене на гітлерів. Я натискаю продовжити і що я тут маю зробити я маю надати можливість віжуал-студію коди використовувати які Власне, дії читати мою інформацію інформацію про користувача адресу пошти тощо.
натискаю відкрите відповідне посилання і здається, все наступний крок наступний крок я ж, не був тим кому Павло Володимирович дозволив працювати з відповідними репозиторами тобто я нагло вдерся я вкрав Так, А тепер хочу щось змінити.
нову Ну не тому, що я все ж таки повинен мати доступ. До репозитарію, яким чином це павло Володимирович, зробить він Наразі, увімкне Власне кажучи, свій екран, і покаже ще раз, що він може додати додати за адресою електронної пошти користувача.
До репозитарію, Давайте подивимося, як це ви зробите?
вказуємо додати людей наскільки я пам'ятаю, воно було щось такого типу: правильно?
Так саме за відповідним а ім'ям або адресою електронною поштою, як вам буде зручно будь ласка, давайте за ім'ям запросимо.
Сергій.
Так за ім'ям, простіше тому що загалом ця людина має бути Зареєстрована на гітхабів якщо ви не зареєстровані, то можливості, не буде і ми пробуємо додати от нас показує що поки що в процесі тобто Сергій олексійович не прийняв ще запрошення.
піз запросив до відповідного репозитарію. Запрошення воно має термін дії 7 діб Так що Будь ласка, не затягуйте сприйняттям запрошень я передглядаю це запрошення Ось воно.
розуміємо. І ось відбувається. Відправка відправка ви бачите що тут модифікації тощо.
І давайте подивимося, на те, що виконується у нас в репогетарі не просто з'явилося оце щось а ви чітко бачите По-перше, хто виконав дії.
Ось Оцей есемес є той самий надпис який ви вводите що ви саме зробили я написав що модифікував рідний мд, ви також можете подивитися історію.
Цих дій не лише у віжел-студію Давайте поглянемо де в нас відповідні дії виконувалося так у нас були запити Пулу.
Раз те, що я бачу, Ну, здається, що всі вони були закриті тобто тут проблем. Немає. Добре, історія конкретних дій.
Ми можемо подивитися, що там, виконав відповідний користувач ось у нас не чудове візуальне подання бачите біленьким це те, що залишилось незмінним.
Червоним зі знаком мінус це те, що буде видалено я нічого не віддаляю тут Зелене зі знаком плюс що я щось додав і адміністратор може тут додати коментар, який стосується того, що це додавання в яке мало сенс тощо так тримати і таке, інше.
Що ж Власне, мені вдалося як рядовому користувачеві цього досягнути Дякую. Павло володимировича Так в нас з'явився станіслав станіслав Скажіть будь ласка, у вас Наразі є можливість пустити віже у Студію.
Не чудово тоді давайте як то кажуть, продовжимо в трохи не є іншому. Варіанті Павло Володимирович запрошує.
Yeah.
Так якщо можливо, тоді, пишуть демонстрації крам і ми спробуємо знову ж таки, на цьому прикладі показати як підключити 100 того, самого репозиторію.
І як з ним співпрацювати?
Так.
Так перше, що треба зробити, це я вам скину Наприклад, посилання на свій репертуар щоб.
That was…
Але здається, Павло Володимирович у Станіслава Андрійовича, вже є власні Репозиторії я правильно?
Розумію.
І у вас як а поки що немає так можливо, замість тесту репозиторія як то кажуть, станіслав андрійович ви зараз створите нереальній репертуарі до якого спробуєте підключити, як нас присутніх так і всіх інших, щоб ми якраз це випробували.
Давайте тоді як то кажуть: з чого з ви інтерфейсу, хіт-хап.
Mm-hmm.
Аа.
Так. Тобто, ви тоді можете перейти по або відкрити кітка або перейти по посиланню.
І з вами спробуємо тоді.
Linda?
ім'я можливо, вашої команди тут як це таже Тобто, це буде просто ім'я репозиторів.
Корпорація монстрів.
Так цілком підійде можна опис Але ти не є обов'язком тут вказано, що общено, тому мабуть, ми хочемо щоб це був публічній репозиторії. Тому ми можемо це лишити і єдине, що натиснути додати рік міфайл і Загалом, все і натискайте, створити репозиторію.
Є.
Чудово.
Почути якраз з найголовнішого залучити колег.
Одразу ж запросити до нього.
Так Можливо, в нас якраз є я та віталій Можливо, у них є акаунти на Кіт-ха-ха тому ви можете їх зараз що це в налаштування останній підпункт тут колборейдерсь Так і тут додати людей, з етпіпу от, і або по пошта.
Можливо, можете вказати я не або віталій Вашії, І зерна користувацькі вина не відхаб.
Можна поки що додати сергій Олексійович та моє не відомо, зараз Є своє погляння як воно: точно було ось так щоб не переплутати, і ось моє має бути по ось цьому також можете спробувати додати.
Uh-huh.
От воно є Чудово. От, І Віталія. Якраз також додав.
І можемо зараз всі прийняти запрошення. Відстаньслав.
Я прийняв Тому. Зараз я думаю, що якщо виновити сторінку, має показувати то прийняв запрошення.
натисніть зелена ось така кнопочка. Код так і ось тут бачите в нас вимагає так і юра Тепер приходьте назад. В жу-студія тут натисніть файл і нове вікно.
Так. Ось тут. У нас є клонування репозитація кіт натискайте ваше посилання тут. Вам треба бути помирати, куди це саме.
Чудово, і відкрите.
І от, як бачите, у нас є базовий файл і можете, спробувати. Давайте спробуємо додати?
В який опис можна українською що цей репозиторій для сайту корпорації монстрів щось такого.
Чудово! Тепер треба зберегти Контрол. С.
Так і от, бачите, у нас якраз букові панель ціна з'явилася 1 на третьому?
Так рапіконці і Бачите, у нас тут показують якісь зміни тобто рідні і історію загальних ваших пам'ять у нас лише 1 поміт це створення репозиторів, і ми хочемо додати ті зміни тому нам треба навпроти відмі на тетиснути знак плюс.
Це додасть. Його в пакет змін тепер нам треба вказати повідомлення тут можна вказати що.
Explain me.
Так. Ну тут.
Власне кажучи, вільний текст вказуйте додали опис от просто зі словами: напишіть і додали опис.
І так якось можна прибрати.
А.
Так. Так. Ну Але ж як то Хай буде експериментуємо.
I'm supposed to say.
Дякую.
Так тобто, казав опис ім'я може бути довільне далі. Можна звісно ж, як сергій одразу натиснувши так і це буде третя тобто, комі і відправка так?
No.
Я чекаю.
В даному випадку ні. Загалом, Немає потреби в цьому так у вас Який розвиє вже встановлено все тому має бути налаштовано.
Так, ми бачимо щось зміна відбулась і Загалом Тепер будь-хто з колег які доєднався до вашої пропозиції, можуть терпити.
Тобто загалом, сюди ви можете завантажити свій сайт, який ви будете розробляти і співпрацювати з ним, всі разом.
Так. Ні, це фактично історія коміків. Тобто, бачите у нас є інший комітет те, що ви вперше створили якийсь файл.
Новий і вона додасть, повернутися в перший сюди створити якийсь стан будь-який.
Mm-hmm.
Так, і в якийсь текст тут додати наприклад, Так, зберігаємо файл повертаємось до контроль версіями.
Додаємо файл того пакету змін додаємо повідомлення новий файл наприклад.
Awesome.
І так відправляємо і бачите у вас одразу додалось тобто це буде історія. Камітів.
Mm-hmm.
випадку файла не було того, ми фактично додали текст і це відображається тим, що в нас плюс і зелене що ми додали якийсь новий контент мінус у червоний значить, що ми якийсь контент прибрали.
Wit kat. Ambo.
To call…
Так? У даному випадку це буде трошки складніше тому.
On the way too.
Have a suggestion.
З назви нижче. Цього ні ні ні той що другий нас натисніть правою кнопкою.
Okay. Awesome.
Миші. Тут вас має бути.
Кар-а мам путь третє.
Мені здається, так от і ось це на саме таке кину але воно прибирає всі що були до цього.
Oh, mm-hmm.
О тобто прибрати окремі буде досить важко але якщо це ви хочете прибирати всі що поле до того, ось таким шляхом це можна побачити.
The file.
Mm-hmm.
Щоб отримати все там якщо повернетесь тут додали опис зверху. В цьому графі третє і конка витягувати вона називайте це буде ось тобто так, тому що немає ніяких змін.
Take a call.
No. I want to book in a particular tutor.
Тому фактично вона і не буде працювати не давно.
Mm-hmm.
They're cool.
Я думаю, що тоді з цього все, звісно, якщо є питання, якісь можливості хтось хоче спробувати.
Цілком можемо переглянути.
Of principle puttan namaya.
Добре, і щоб повернутися тому що зараз це воно вказало фактично так тут, можете це закинути ці зміни.
Е.
Hmm.
От, Тобто додали ви бачите що Сергій Олексійович і там зміни. Є.
Може це можна побачити в історії, феміди щоб це закинути Я думаю, що вам треба.
Mm-hmm.
Ми так мене є підозр що воно не є добре, оновленим.
Спробуйте знизу, там єсть ось в нижньому лівому кутку.
Так.
Well, that's…
Так ось тут класність на сюди на гілки так і тут я думаю, можна буде переключитись на гілку мейн, просто Дивно, чим у вашому випадку, трошки я дивлюсь що в мене є у мене трошки відрізняється від вашого натисніть на мене.
От вона б повернула всі зміни. Не можу зрозуміти чому.
Де так тут. Ви можете вказати це повідомлення.
Я думаю, зараз треба поглянути тому що відповідно функціонал має бути.
Якраз ви бачите, що в нас є певний конфлікт, тощо, потрібно обрати, які зміни, є суті.
To choose Lamallas.
А так тут, бачите якщо повернетесь до рідний файло який у вас був обраний.
От Він червоний бачите і тут Можна прийняти або обидві зміни це третій пункт такий його можете загалом натиснути якщо ви хочете прийняти вид от і у вас злилось.
Mm-hmm.
Те, що Сергій Олексійович казав і те, що ви казали, і Тепер ви зможете спробувати ще раз.
Продовжити, треба натиснути тут от, і тепер у вас буде 2 коміту, Так ви перше, злили у битві бо змін і потім намагалися все ж таки свіщаками.
Uh-hmm.
Ось коли декілька користувачів, правлять. 1 і той самий файл, вони можуть правити різні фрагменти хтось щось і таке інше, але якщо вони зберігають одночасно.
Back 7.
Яка ситуація, виникає що потрібно визначити, які зміни, потрібно внести.
Repository. I should say pretty much… Mm-hmm.
Ні вони будуть всім приходить тобто кожен користувач має одні й ті самі зміни.
Готовий.
Sebab.
Рад.
Chini.
Mm-hmm.
файл був зредагований і конкретно для вас виникла конфлікт, який треба вирішити наприклад, змінити цей файл.
Тобто кожна окрема людина, яка отримати конфлікт тобто, якщо ви наприклад, закрите зміни.
Wow. Mm-hmm.
А Віталій або Яна намагатимуться змінити його в себе У той же час, без отримання ваших змін.
Вони отримують той самий конфлікт, який треба буде вирішити.
Mm-hmm.
У будь-якому випадку, як то кажуть врешті-решт, робиться Організаційно якщо дійсно визначається певна особа, яка є головна в то в назві відповідно контроль коду, тощо. То врешті-решт, остаточне рішення за неї, Але це питання домовленості у вас в команді.
To the one email.
Mm-hmm.
Наприклад, закинули до головної гілки і це буде досить швидко і ефективно.
Ого зрозуміло.
Так. Можливо, ще є якісь питання? Стосовно цього?
Поки немає дивіться а якщо все було велю зараз файл так, то він все одно залишився в репозиторі і я не зможу зробити так, щоб в опозиторів не було це тільки сюди.
Власне, якщо його ви видалити локально так і цю зміну надішлете до репозитарію, вийти і надішлете на гітхабі фізично, цей Файл буде вилили але історія змін збережеться, давайте спробуйте це зробити і ви побачите що він Зникне, і там.
Та.
Ну.
Тут у цьому випадку, бачите, у вас таке ж сам повідомлення як Сергій олексійович чи що треба вказати, комід повідомлення Тобто треба писати, в цьому Файлі і можете, додати до цього, Михайлю, щоб був відкритий.
На.
Ну ось сюди.
Так, на перший рядок так, тобто вказуйте.
О ну. Так.
Так і треба тепер прийняти що ви закінчили. Редагування і це мені не видно всього, вашого екрану але там в правому кутку має бути от, Так Так прийнят от, натискаєте.
Галочка.
Аго. Дай-но. Його Немає. Так.
Показую, що нема такого більш топових видав.
Прикольно. Це Ви все прикольно.
Угу.
файл і тоді можна буде його там відобразити.
Ого!
Добре.
Загалом якщо питань, більше немає чи можливо, в інших є питання.
А де по подивитися на сайті саме на коміти останні які були Ну, це напевно, тиснути.
А все бачимо.
Ого!
коміт на назву і побачите, що саме було зроблено.
То от навіть що саме: а плюсики висів? Це що?
Так Тобто, бачите тут.
Це ви можете а ви можете натиснути і бачите можете додавати коментарі, Наприклад, вам не сподобалось те, що зробив все геніально.
А в коментарі.
І чи ви хочете казати що це треба робити, інакше?
Ні. Не тільки.
Яка фігня? Так.
Ого!
У не зрозумів.
рядки.
Угу Ні. Ну, се Оце круто. Саме що Подивися що було змінено що було видалено класно.
Причому не просто подивитися, а ви маєте можливість. Управління безпосередньо Тобто якщо роздивитися, те, що стосується там або відповідна ще сторінка 3 крапки то можна якраз виконати певні дії.
3 крапки. Ну, Це бій файл є тут.
У крапки Ви можете тут переглянути відповідний файл, і що власне було зроблено раз і Павло володимирович?
Підкажіть Яким чином ми можемо безпосередньо тут у відповідному інтерфейсі.
Не відкотити, ці зміни. Відмінити.
Настільки я знаю, не впевнений, що це можна зробити за допомогою його під хабу в самому Кіт-хабі тут студії лише можливо, за допомогою без використання терміналу Звісно, ж, лише використовуючи відповідні, додаткові.
Окрім того, не те, що вулиця.
Ого!
І ви бачите що у вас ви можете бачити, стан репортажі у той момент, коли була зроблена зміна коли Файл 1 пшп ще існував і таке інше.
Це. Так.
Ого. Ну, Так. Я бачу що тут є.
Але все можна відстежити.
Файл і комітету замінити як зміна тексту Он тут.
Так тобто фактично можна переглянути з будь-якої позиції але треба враховувати те, що прибрати історію не можна то дано випадку ви не зможете так легко прибрати з історії. Що щось було зроблено з цим треба бути також обережним.
Тому що можна буде легко зрозуміти, що було зроблено наприклад, ви також кидаєте, багато повідомлень, багато комісій то це також Нині дуже добре.
Тому що тут буде багато всяких змін, і все буде не недовги.
Так, буде трошки незрозумілим, але загалом, Таким чином, бачить можна так можна і перевіряти користувача.
Жартувати.
Який робив ці зміни.
Ой, й за це може вибрати задатою.
Так Тобто можна переглядати дуже велику кількість різних дій, які були створені.
Тому цілком.
Можна використовувати в такий спосіб, як бачите, для ваших проєктів це буде досить корисно і досить зручно.
Навіть якщо у вас немає багато досвіду то бачите, що можна налаштувати ми близько 20 хвилин, витратили на загальне налаштування припозиторію, створення так з урахуванням що ми створювали нові репорторі тому я думаю, що цілком швидко.
І то там навіть менше. Навіть здається, ні.
Він добре, тоді якщо з цією частиною закінчили ми можемо перейти то нашого стендапу який сьогодні також буде на жаль, бачу, у нас лише перша команда але можемо послухати, загалом перша команда які у вас успіхи, є якісь проблеми, як загалом прогрес з розробкою монстрапедії.
платформу Вікс і за цього було вирішено брати Спочатку платформу Віскс Ну, і тепер бачимо, що можна працювати з іншими засобами.
Через гітхапи Це дуже зручно. Не так зручно. Як Можливо, у віці бо там все в онлайні Але для візол коду це дуже круто.
В умовах.
Дуже крутий і цікавий досвід.
Тактуватимеш?
Тому поки все робимо і чекаємо від дизайнерів так скажемо і будемо починати робити.
Та.
Ченчес для того, щоб отримати Резерв так що можна йти.
Ну, Так. Ну, і в ідеалі, ви маєте тестувати ваші зміни. Коли ви їх робите ось якщо ви їх відправите то звісно, ваші колеги будуть мабуть, так вони будуть дуже раді таким змінам тому звісно, що їх треба.
Ну, це Так.
Рогатись. Дуже сильно можемо.
Тестувати Загалом наскільки я пам'ятаю, у вас були питання стосовно сайту.
На минулому синтапі 8 клас якщо я пам'ятаю правильно то це було за шапку сайту вас бульне зростання.
Були Там Питання з дизайнерів, але сьогодні зараз немає заману. Ми Там вирішили як це можна зробити лопокажем.
Може щось там додати щось прибирати але в принципі, ми вже вирішили що буде в шапці плюс-мінус я можу питання закрити поки що?
Добре, можливо, у вас є якісь приклади? Від дизайнерів, щоб розуміти чи йдемо, в правильному напрямку, чи що побачити, якісь основи, чи поки що.
Просто без них показувати Я не знаю, у нас ще поки немає вони там працюють.
Чому?
дивитесь В: Дякую.
А можна тоді вас попросити записати бо чи воно йде запис, Так. Йде зустріч.
невеличкий блоці які стосуються принципів дизайн як розробники, ми ж не просто реалізуємо якусь функціоналість ми створимо продукти з якими взаємодія реальний користувач не розуміння основних принципів, дизайну, вам допоможе створити якісний і зручний
інтерфейс навіть якщо ви не є професійним дизайнером, Я не вмієте доцільним чином, розробляти дизайни, компонувати тощо.
Як ті, в кого як то кажуть, немає відповідного таланту наймані способи шаблони для виконання відповідних дій і Подивимося, з точки зору саме веб-розробника ось основний перелік принципів дизайну саме для видатків головнішого з ієрархії та візуального балансу мова йде про
Відповідну організацію ваших елементів за важливістю Ось тут ви бачите що певним чином впорядковане там заголовки це логічні елементи які ви використовуєте абзаци первинні кнопки вторинні кнопки і таке інше.
Що тут використовується для визначення за важливістю. Знову ж таки, мова йде про розмір Насамперед, ви бачите, тут розмір фонду.
2 з половиною для заголовку першого рівня відповідно для звичайного абзацу розмір 1 тощо.
дещо різного розміру але первинні є більшими вторинні є меншими так, що навіть якщо не малюєте будь ласка, оперуйте розміром кольору розташуванням для того, щоб створювати Ось таку певну ієрархію відповідними налаштуванню це все про ксеміті це не спосіб пов'язати ті елементи
які мають розташовані бути близько не 1 від одного, Тобто таке собі групування ось ви бачите в нас скажімо, є ціла ієрархія там якась картка заголовок відповідної картки далі вміст картки тощо.
Цей принцип використовується не разом із принципом, який носить назву принцип контрасту так перепрошую Я його тут трохи інакше, спробував зробити ось принцип, контракту відмінностей.
Для виділення важливих елементів в узгодженості Найголовніше, щоб вони Навпаки, виглядали і поводилися однаково Наприклад, ось ви бачите елементи які є у згущеними.
Всі елементи які належать відповідні групи, мають однаковий та відступи однаковий відповідний уконтовки, однаковий світ і таке інше.
Хочете змінити для Хочете змінити. Щось пов'язане з цими елементами. Будь ласка, змінюйте для групи у цілому.
кнопку то виможете імітувати оцю дію матері іскання тобто на короткий час перетворюється зникає оця рамка і кнопка нібито буде це трохи опущеною а далі при піднята ось такий візуальний варіант є ще інші елементи наприклад, вводити на цю кнопку а на фокус свого до попадає будь
ласка, ви можете прибирати в неї Як це називається тінь. Від кнопки і таке інше.
Типовий варіант який використовується для зворотного зв'язку, приклад коли ви потрапляєте до певного поля воно підсвічується чи певним чином, виділяється в ньому змінюється шрифт і таке інше.
Щось зробив і щось відповідним чином відбулося для цього Перепрошую, не Потрібно виконувати дії на рівні опрацювання повідомлені таким чином для цього достатньо.
користувач. Це Зазвичай не вважає Дальше Розміщуйте важливі елементи ще до типових позицій.
Курсура та пальця. Типова Позиція це ближче до середини. Екрану Не змушуйте користувача.
Копирсатися в Якійсь окремій куті екрану в той час як інша складова вона не буде застосовуватися тобто робіть більше збільшуйте активну зону для кно упок і таке інше.
Пам'ятайте, що ви маєте це ж інтерфейс? Користувача. Маєте це зробити? А це означає?
Що ви маєте розуміти, чим він насамперед, послуговується?
Сучасний веб-додатки У нас користувачі переглядають насамперед на мобільних пристроях.
самий код. Це у вас кліп але різне єс оформлення для відповідне різних елементів.
Найдоцільнішим Тут зробити урахування того, що не ваш веб-додаток може бути принаймні у двох орієнтаціях це не орієнтація альбом.
На. Типова наприклад, для ноутбука, коли в ширину більше, ніж висоту і портретна типовна як ви тримаєте телефон вертикальна відповідна орієнтація для того, щоб доцільним чином, це урахувати та я рекомендую не використовувати відповідні сучасні інструменти для створення
гнучких та адаптивних пакетів, такі як відповідні сітки Ссс та не Флекс-бокс з інших речей, які є суттєвими це не послуговуйтеся абсолютними розмірами хоча тут я навів приклад ви бачите, в пікселях Використовуйте відносні одиниці вимірювання у відносних
одиницях такі як Відповідно, Ар'єм В Юпої сьюніс Віаш це відповідно у висоту віддабою це у ширину Це дозволяє елементи, масштабувати відповідно розміру екрана або налаштування користувача це якраз дуже зручно якщо ви використовуєте ось у такій системі а не в
пікселях розміри екранів Значить, відносні розміри шрифту відносні висоти вікна перегляду відносні ширини вікна перегляду а також дії які пов'язані о зі ступеня заповнення наприклад, заповнені на 100 заповнення на 50 Ось, так Скажімо, можна завжди розрахувати центр який би у
вас не був адаптація передбачає також ті графічні елементи які ви створюєте.
Тобто власне, мова йде про адаптивні зображення, різних розмірів екрану це можуть бути фізично, різні зображення, власне кажучи, нереальний варіант але основний варіант, який я рекомендую це щоб у вас були векторні зображення, тобто не чіптек не пінжі, а зображення, у форматі S
називаються Що таке дизайн? Доки не це відступи це кольори. Це типографіка далі.
Другим елементом є власне дизайн-компоненти дизайн-компонентами.
В нас класично виступає кнопки. Не форми та відповідно. Картки в патерними є класичними це пошук навігація таблиці і звісно, принципи і правила зростання популярні системи дизайну який я намагався навести не всі є нові але власне це справді фірмові системи дизайну за кожної з
них стоїть Якась Відома корпорація. Наприклад, матеріал дизайн Айс це Майкрософт якщо ви полковник Епол то у вас буде аж Аджі х'юмен інтерфейс навіть пропонує власний дизайн Латс Латнінг дизайн системи Використання системи дизайну воно має переваги,
власне щодо того, маєте узгодженість Тобто всі гулівські продукти виконані в стилі матеріал дизайн вони виглядають дуже поголівськи прискорюється розробка і тут буде краще комунікація між дизайнерами розробляють лише окремі компоненти графічні тощо.
Але вибір системи дизайну. Це достатньо важливим. Врешті-решт тоді це буде достатньо масштабовано. Роботи.
Що я пропонував використовувати можете готові бібліотеки. Компонентів для матеріал, дизайну Будь ласка, матеріливії, будстрап можете використовувати та тейл він тощо.
Купа їх ви можете створити власні компоненти з використанням цих фізичних та компонентного підходу.
Ну, і звісно, у вашій роботі. Вам потрібно буде документувати не компоненти не вашої команди так що дизайн це не лише ті дизайнери, які займаються виключно графічним дизайном.
Дизайн. Це, також. Ви Будь ласка, залучайтесь питання. Власної доступності.
формі, яку користувачі можуть сприйняти погано я бачу значить, Мені потрібно щось крупне з невеликою кількістю компонентів таке інше: та енергосистеми мають бути функціональними для різних способів взаємодії використовує руки.
Пальцями відповідний дач інтерфейс, а хтось використовує ми що значить, кнопку.
Я повинен натиснути як мишею так і пальцем, промахуюсь кнопки або намагалися натиснути декілька одноразово далі.
доступності ви маєте використовувати пропоную вам використовувати семантичну розмітку, коли ви використовуєте правильний аштемейл елементи для відповідного призначення, цей доступний от він більш є і зрозумілим, перепрошую там з дужками.
табуляцією дійти до відповідної гіперпосилання і таке інше. Так що доступний код він є й універсальним і більш застосованим для розширення семантики рекомендуюся використовувати відповідні не аатрибути ось ви бачите, що в нас встановлені наприклад, осі Арія Лейбл для
співвідношення контрастності 3: до одного до великого тексту, 18 пунктів і таке інше.
У випадку недоступності елементу не завантажується певне зображення тощо.
Будь ласка, рубіть для нього. Альтернативний текст ну і якщо використовуєте структуру, яка пов'язана з заголовками, будь ласка, не пропускайте рівні розпочинайте нам з першого рівня, далі другий і таке інше.
Для веб-дизайнерів є багато інструментів для тестування доступності ну наприклад, там виф евелошин тулекс і таке інше власне кажучи, в храмі у дифтус навіть є відповідні елементи для того, щоб подивитися на цьому слайді якраз перелічені найпоширеніші інструменти для
код і серед інших популярних експериментів. Це добикс кетч під макоїв.
підхід і таке інше. Друге це маніпуляція та обробка подій насамперед диригування збереження даних у тому числі великого розміру ви дізналися, що в браузері є гарна вбудована база даних і не 1 і таке інше.
дизайн що ж Дякую. Будь ласка, які у нас є питання: завдання. І таке інше.
Павло Володимирович що нам ще потрібно?
Загалом від двох, Псемпа якраз часу. Забрали ще 5 хвилин. Хто?
Ну ось тоді вибачаємося за відповідну затримку. І Сподіваємося, зустрітися наступного тижня.
В нас принаймні декілька зустрічей має бути що здоров'я гарних робочих вам вихідних щоб ваші результати із відповідним чином вже почали потихеньку інтегруватися, тому Беріть за хвіст дизайнерів і Подивимося, який дизайн вони нам створять.
Дякую. Велике.
До побачення.